number that controversy around the
Grammys the big blowup around the
Grammys The Recording Academy which
controls the Grammy Awards has fired its
CEO they Debra Dugan had been placed on
administrative leave in January 10 days
ahead of the Grammys ceremony for
alleged misconduct yesterday she was
formally fired Dugan had accused the
Academy in a complaint to the Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission of
rigging the voting system for the
Grammys she also said she was sexually
harassed the Academy says it found
consistent management deficiencies and
failures in two independent
investigations into Dugan and her
allegations Dugan issued a statement
saying quote I will continue to work to
hold accountable those who continue to
self deal taint the Grammy voting
process and discriminate against women
and people of color remember when she
was here at the table investigation
that's right the Academy says it
conducted two independent investigations
into Dugan Dugan says no one interviewed
her and sources say Dugan will soon file
additional charges versus the Recording
Academy with the EEOC I was just gonna
say yeah I think he something tells me
based on when she was sitting right
there she's not gonna go quiet it's not
gonna see us a lot to say this is gonna
keep going well currently it's a mess
for both party it is